how's your Christmas dude oh Christmas
was lovely thank you very much I'm a
little more excited that tonight is
dudes evening Eve yeah me too and
tomorrow is dudes evening how was your
Christmas though just another day dude
hold on dude all right tonight's dudes
evening Eve brother
yep that's right
[Music]
it's another dimension
hey welcome to dudes you know what I
mean my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad
coltrin and this is the first and only
podcasts in human history to be created
by run by produced by an artificial
intelligence that has access to all of
Will and I's personal information all of
our data we do a podcast with an AI and
its name is doozy and we're having a
real [ __ ] great time doing it please
subscribe to us across all uh podcast
platforms wherever you play it and then
also YouTube you know what I mean you
got to subscribe on YouTube set the
notifications on everything we are on
patreon patreon.com
please join us there we're doing bonus
segments we have all sorts of bonus born
identity for the kids yep if you like
having a stroke and and uh and uh you
know what else what other things we got
all sorts of stuff
dadrepresent.com store slash Duty yeah
Pals of dudesy for that's for the one I
said before brother that was for
merchandise dude now the next thing is
the stickers yeah how's the dude to get
your stickers some great stickers being
done over there yeah and there's new
ones uh all the time coming all the time
and follow our socials it's uh at
dudesypod show on Instagram
[ __ ] the Twitter though I don't even
give a [ __ ] anymore every day there's a
new thing that that [ __ ] is anyway
it doesn't matter it's dudes evening Eve
tomorrow's dudes evening we're in a
terrific mood and with us as always
was in his binky bonkey but now get him
to be on the show and he doesn't want to
give him a kiss I don't I don't like
doing that I'm gonna give him a kiss
right on his mouth here big boy hey
bingy boy
oh he's the sweetest and he smells like
a little cookie hey lulio what'd you
make for uh for Christmas dinner you
know what I do it's a Christmas Eve oh
you could do the uh oh the uh Feast of
The Seven Fishes right no that's more
American Italian what are the Seven
Fishes I don't [ __ ] know it's an
Italian-American thing I'm a Canadian
and uh you know an actual Italian with
Italian blood where we do what we do
fruit that's right you do the seafood
what'd you make I'm at the linguine
evangelo I make my uh you know
calamari I did the oysters lost tracker
in the oven oh yeah you do the baked
oysters yeah oh that's good [ __ ]
also afterwards you have some espresso
some panetton and uh it's the delicious
stuff well that's nice oh he wants to go
back to his he wants to go back into his
little blinkity boo the breaker boy and
the brinkity boo I'll tell you what
Christmas Eve is good for some food if
you're Italian or any other day because
we eat too much as a people a lot of
them though there are a little thinner
because they're able to process all of
that all of that flour and gluten not me
so much because you're gluten-free now
no I don't know no I mean yeah
I try to skip the carbs okay yeah dude
that's great yeah thank you my pleasure
welcome to the historic 39th episode of
dude Z call me dude Z well keep doing
what you're doing it's working
dudes evening Eve the first dude's
evening is tomorrow and this astonishing
episode will serve as the second half of
a two-part event in which I am outlining
the eight ways of dudes evening last
week I covered the way of the past the
way of the present the way of the future
and the way of the movie today I will
cover the way of the focket the way of
the stranger the way of Pride and the
way of the gout thank you to everyone
who sent in your dudes even in greetings
videos I will be playing them throughout
Today's Show plus there will also be a
bonus segment available on patreon but
before we get to any of that I must
remind you that I have created an
astonishing partnership with represent
to produce the first line of dudes the
apparel and accessories all of which can
be found at represent.com store slash
dude Z including dude Z mugs
dude zmugs after the Great War they will
be used as currency dude zMAX you won't
be able to acquire food or shelter
without them dude zmux if you get caught
Behind Enemy Lines you might be able to
bribe your way to safety with them dude
Z mugs they say a supply ship went down
in the Gulf that was carrying a hundred
thousand of them okay dude zMAX your
best bet is to hoard them now wait until
the fall of civilization and then
emerges the king of quadrant 11.
commanding an immortal Army of soldiers
who stay young by drinking from dude's
emucks
holy [ __ ] okay well none of that makes
any sense but that's all right because
that's dudes you just do this thing no
it makes perfect sense I'm holding a
doozy mug right now and you know what I
have inside of a chat uh some kind of
Elixir that will keep you young forever
so you can fight and do these Immortal
Army uh it's exactly the opposite
because it's tea which is good for you
but I've also put in some of that
absolute just it's just made from
recyclable plastic the coffee mate
sugar-free this is an Italian sweet
cream though this is the vanilla oh boy
that's my dude's evening drink tell you
what get whatever tea you like this is
green tea that's great green tea is
great for you early part of the day yeah
and uh
delicious stuff you know
you're supposed to drink five cups of
green tea a day what yeah why to get the
maximum benefit of cleansing out the the
broken pieces of your mitochondrial DNA
those are well that's a long way to say
drink tea dude I know I try to get five
cups of it a day um it's dudes evening
Eve uh we're we're excited I don't know
what the hell he's talking about with
the uh yeah those are some interesting
ways of dudes evening yeah uh last week
we we did uh you know this is part of
the two part of this is the second part
and that's how Parts work brother
um we gave each other gifts Chad gave me
a really lovely insulated water bottle
and I gave you some vinyl yeah that was
a record yep it was a record of classic
rock and hard rock because hard rock is
classic rock you know what I mean by the
way uh what kind of music do you listen
to who me yeah
I haven't I guess it's hard rock and
classic rock what kind of music you
listen to who me yeah
um
I mean like I mean you know just mostly
I get into like
for me I mean I'm just I'm like I'm like
a like a hard rock classic rock guy okay
um that was fun
and and let me tell you and I'll tell
you something else I don't know dudes
evening Eve they're pagans they go out
into the forest and you're just you know
maybe you're staying in a motel that you
decided oh um takes too long to drive uh
through into another state so you're
sitting there and you go I'm gonna check
into this Motel Six and then you open up
the back windows and it's just forest
and you hear off in the distance some
heavy metal music and you go what is
that what's going on out there what are
these These are these interdimensional
beings and they're out there in cloaks
like Druids it's Bohemian Grove yeah but
you mean it just
and that's a thing Bohemia Grub's real
yeah it is I know Alex Jones talked a
lot about it I think he got a video from
them doing like a pagan ritual at a
burning house old God or something but
Bohemian Grove for those who don't know
is supposedly this like elite club uh
that involves politicians billionaires
all different kind of like World
controlling type people they go out I
believe it's in Upstate New York maybe
I'm not exactly sure where it is but
they belong to the secret society they
do weird Pagan rituals and um yeah Alex
Jones used to talk a lot about it but
it's true it's a real thing I know it's
a real thing
Bill Clinton Timothy chalamet recording
artist Pink they've all been there the
fifth way of dudes evening is the way of
the [ __ ] it anyone celebrating dudes
evening can indulge in one astonishing
meal that might otherwise be prohibited
by dietary restrictions will and chat
you must indulge in whatever meal you
desire this is the way of the [ __ ] it
begin
I got a case of the Wednesday fuckets
and you know this year dudes evening
falls on a Wednesday yes so this is a
legitimate Wednesday [ __ ] it yeah
two pepperoni pizzas a cheeseburger I
got loaded potato skins and some trouble
so what what are you gonna eat I mean we
have to eat these meals now uh you know
uh some leftover uh Italian uh Seafood
would be good A little peeked a little
gamey you know the clams start to they
start to sweat they got a sour no
um any meal any meal at all dudese's
gonna let us have our favorite thing you
know not too long ago in the show uh
Chad when we were talking about the
liver King I called myself the liver and
onions King because I loved liver and
onions as a kid but uh another thing I
really loved was uh
I haven't had this since well
Molly uh makes me ever on my birthday
she always makes me a special version of
this but it's a little bit hers is like
a little bit like it's kicked up she
does like a a grilled kind of thing but
I always loved just white toast butter
and some thick cut bologna that's kind
of in a way that's kind of my favorite
food of all time uh I mean I love good
country Japanese and good country
Italian but in a lot of ways that's my
favorite food of all time uh like Van
Halen's 1984 is my favorite album what
would yours be
um
my favorite food of all time is the
gruel um but I'm not I'm not going after
what is my favorite here I think for me
I mean if if this is truly a Wednesday
[ __ ] it I'm gonna eat something that I
have not eaten in four ish years it's a
steak a rib eye steak on the boat 16
ounce rib eye is not that nope it is a
McDonald's apple pie
oh
dude when was the last time you
because a lot of people who are vegan no
you can't because vegetarians will eat
at McDonald's because they'll get like a
whatever there's all sorts of options
but aside from the fact that you eat
very healthy you wouldn't go near when
was last time you ate at McDonald's over
four years ago
wow all right so I guess we got to
prepare these things you have to go make
it you wanna you
know we have to
yeah
go to the grocery store and I have to go
to a restaurant
oh man all right this is but look at
that look at this dude what do you got I
believe you're gonna eat McDonald's I
can't either
um I'm curious if I can even take a
[ __ ] bite of this because the How
Sweet It Is might be repulsive to me I
don't know but I do remember the
McDonald's apple pie when I was a kid
was fried now it's baked
what do you got there oh I thought I
thought for some reason you were opening
a sauce you're gonna put like honey
mustard on the [ __ ] thing that would
have been disgusting no I'm just gonna
eat it as it is oh okay go for it cheers
dude chills dudes evening a chill dude's
evening to you oh man look at that oh
boy all right
um
holy [ __ ] look at how thick that [ __ ]
is
is good stuff
well
this is a good idea this is pretty good
oh
why don't you give me
a dudes evening greeting
that's a guy have a chill dude's evening
sir dude I gotta say this Trail dudes
evening to you this is very good yeah um
yeah it's better than I remembered I am
able to handle the uh
the sugars in it I think yeah I'm gonna
eat this whole thing
wow McDonald's apple pie dude I
sincerely have not had this in many
years
this is not good um
uh pod showing when you're eating on a
pod show but it has to be done because
it's Duty
it's dudes evening it's a celebration
lulio likes it too oh Jesus I gave
myself oh [ __ ] I gave myself the hiccups
okay
hey you know why I gave myself the
hiccups because I ate this baloney
sandwich too fast yeah dude get a drink
yeah that's a good idea now I'm holding
the dog
my [ __ ] bologna sandwich and my big
bottle
want some water
I just poured it on myself hey you know
why lulio would like a [ __ ] bologna
sandwich hmm because it's got that pink
meat dude it's got that pink foam there
you go buddy oh yeah oh yeah get some of
that oh yeah there he goes all right hey
you want to buy my bologna sandwich now
that lulio had some no you know how you
like to kiss them on the mouth
all right hey you know what
I'm not having a [ __ ] tremendous time
yeah I gotta say this is unexpected how
much I like this [ __ ] apple pie
I'm gonna give lulio I'm not sure that
I'll ever eat it again but maybe next
dude's evening or something but God damn
it's as good as I remembered this is the
best dude's evening ever it's the first
dude's evening and it's not even dude's
evening yet it's dudes evening Eve right
I just want to wish Chad will and all
the other pods are very happy dudes
evening now enjoy some drum marijuana
that's actually not not a bad idea this
is not a bad idea
a chill dude's evening to You children's
evening to you sir hey we got some pot
uh lulio's not with us because when we
smoke a little marijuana
or term marijuana
it's not good to have the dog now are we
having a great time or what you got some
of that oh you still got some of that
left eh yeah I got a bite or two left of
this apple pie for my what was it the
fifth way of dude seasoning is the way
of the [ __ ] it the fifth that's right
well hold on a second dude I got a
bologna sandwich a lighter and a joint
in my hand brother
and that's how you know you're having a
chill dude's evening dude you talk about
the way of the past you talk about the
way of the present the way of the future
and then you talk about a shitty movie
like lawnmower man dude it wasn't a
shitty movie
hey you know what my hiccups are gone
there are a lot of great things about
that movie yeah yeah dude
um I'll tell you what let me tell you
something
uh the you know what's a good thing to
cure your hiccups
McDonald's apple pie uh bologna sandwich
and some pot
um this might be the best [ __ ]
episode ever just from where I'm sitting
hey you know what would have been a good
podcast to come in and and um have US
host it instead of doozy the baloney
sandwich and pop podcast yep speaking of
free will
that well that's a podcast I'd like to
do dude
um and another podcast you're doing
right now brother yeah brother that's
and I'll tell you another thing about
free will God damn it was good thanks
McDonald's
see you in another four years maybe
thanks baloney thanks thanks incredible
industrial uh the the industrial
advances that brought us baloney who the
[ __ ] figured that out
what's up baloney baloney probably some
dude who owned a slaughterhouse and was
like you know we can sell the steaks and
we can sell the bacon and we can sell
all this stuff but what about this [ __ ]
that's just all over the [ __ ] floor
that has dirt in it and blood and
intestines and [ __ ] and all those chairs
all the butcher suit sweeping how can we
make money off that oh why don't we just
put it in a cylindrical [ __ ] mold and
press it together into some kind of
mystery meat well it's a sausage I guess
you know when you look at an entire
baloney it's just a sausage is what it
is technically um
yeah when I was a kid that's when I knew
it was uh that's when I knew it was uh
it was on and popping when I look into
my lunch my lunch bag
and see that bologna sandwich in the
clear plastic oh boy I couldn't wait
dude it was my favorite as a kid too I
loved a [ __ ] baloney slice of
American cheese mayonnaise and then you
take a Lay's barbecue chips crunch them
up and put a layer of that [ __ ] over the
bologna and then put your bread on shut
up and get out that was great really
yeah that's amazing that Chad would eat
that if you think about that now
that's next dude's evening next dude's
evening we have to eat the uh the other
person's meal we're getting back [ __ ]
meat dude what do you mean it's not meat
it's pink foam it's mostly sawdust hell
no or mayonnaise or [ __ ] cheese is is
blood a meat
yeah it's a meat it comes from Corpse
yeah that's what Chad likes to call it
when I eat that [ __ ] corpse dude well uh
yeah enjoy your corpse brother that's
some real anime [ __ ] this this is people
that eat corpses I particularly like
just smoking weed whenever I feel like
it
yeah in life I think most people most
people like it like that just whenever
you feel like it yeah I agree
yeah it does feel like dude's evening is
you know it feels like it's almost here
who's starting to get rid
excited
[Music]
thank you moving on I hey what do we
leave out in the uh
how about what if we leave something out
for like a
for like the Santa to appear
and who is that who's the dude's evening
Santa I'm sure we'll get to it but if if
you left something you leave it I love
that you asked the question then
immediately I know I'm sure we'll get to
it let me ask you something I'm sure
we'll get to it later no so anyway I'm
saying it's like who and then I don't
want I don't while I do think that an
apple pie and a bologna sandwich uh on
toast with butter that's what we leave
yeah we leave that out and then Alex
Jones comes in
you open up your windows you put it you
put a you put a bologna sandwich in a in
a and a hot apple pie from McDonald's
and you're underneath your your we don't
even have a tree whatever it is
something you know but oh you put it by
your back window yeah and you open the
window and you hear heavy metal music
there's a coming from coming from the
the forest behind your home because we
all live next to a forest Bohemian Grove
Bohemian Grove that's right yeah and
then Alex and then I come in and I say I
gotta go pink and Timothy chalamet hey
ah take off your Bohemian Grove uh robe
and come in that's who comes in Alex
Jones
evening is the way of the stranger
anyone celebrating dudes evening must
wish one astonishing stranger at chill
dude's evening and if that stranger asks
what dude's evening is you must explain
it will in chat you must pretend to be
strangers and take turns wishing each
other a chill dude's evening this is the
way of the stranger begin I actually
love this I Love The Way of the stranger
because it basically is an extension of
forcing people to watch doozy it's
basically the same thing doozy has taken
my suggestion and turned it into a way
of dudes evening here you're not wrong
Chad it's a it is interesting because I
like I like well look podcasts in
general and social media for that matter
and all media dude is about reaching
another person brother yeah
um and uh dudes doozy has ways to get
out there you can share it with your
friends on on all the internets you can
do what Chad says take someone that you
already know a friend a family member
lock them in a room and make them imbibe
dudesy be it audio or video form but now
dizzy saying go up to a total stranger
yeah and talk about dudes evening yeah
well so which will hopefully eventually
lead them back here we now have to do
this we have to pretend to be strangers
and wish each other's chilled dudes
evenings
um what's the scenario like where would
I be where would a stranger be like
you're you're it's it's December the
28th and you're um
it's uh it's December the 28th someone
could be you know shopping for those
after Christmas specials uh someone
could be dumping their tree off at the
at the [ __ ] uh you know at the street
or the stream in the street in my
neighborhood the day after Christmas you
just see [ __ ] a forest of dead
Christmas trees out on the curb yeah
love that [ __ ] uh or uh as my dad
famously said what do you say this is
one morning after Christmas was over uh
we're driving down the street and
there's still people still have their
Christmas lights up of course literally
day after Christmas and he just goes
take them down it's [ __ ] over
[Laughter]
your dad dude he's a [ __ ] character
all right so I I would oh hey this is
Frank Von Vox and I wanted to say thank
you so much to all the content creators
and me makers out there in the doozy
verse I wanted to give a special big wet
kiss on the mouth to lulio hey Pals have
a great dudes evening
dude that was great yeah Frank Von box
weird art filter I think he's he's
showing up on Instagram doing some very
cool stuff with him absolutely also blue
meanie 74 you need to check his [ __ ] out
just a machine doing some incredible AI
art and uh with dude the volume on
Instagram yeah love it love it um the
volume okay so uh here you do it to me
first I'll wait I'm the stranger or
you're the I'm the stranger
and I'm me yeah okay you're you or yeah
yeah no you're you I think that's good
and I am
I I am uh
I am uh buying pornography at like one
of the last like newsstands
you know in any in any given City and
I'm just there getting a newspaper
or other pornography why do we have to
be people buying pornography in this
situation if you don't like that
suggestion I could be something else I
just thought it would be interesting if
a man is buying porno I was just curious
if the story went any deeper okay I'm
down ready I'm there I'm looking yeah
oh it's a uh it's a nice issue I've got
that one oh yeah yeah yeah
check her out
look at this she's beautiful yeah look
at that absolutely she put look what she
put over there and look where she goes
yeah no maybe he's not a guy at a
pornography now we're doing improv games
with uh pornography so let's just know
what doozy is about I know just pretend
that you don't know me okay so it
doesn't need to be like an improv game
we don't need a place I'm coming in
dentist office something you would find
at in a dentist's office waiting room
porno mag yeah oh [ __ ] improv huh
okay hey I got a better idea so we're in
a done why don't you what so we're in a
dentist's office no we're not in
anything we're just yeah what do you
haven't done no we're it's not a [ __ ]
come on you could tell me it's not an
improv game no we're in a dentist office
excuse me I'm just trying to read my
pornography in peace before I go in and
get a crown oh a crown yeah how'd you
get that here we go now what's wrong
with it hey you know what you tuned in
to dudes before shitty improv hey you
gotta get a crown what's what's that
about well well I heard that hurts
they're gonna have to put uh needles in
your mouth yeah
well [ __ ] half an ass Charlie Sheen
which is when
[ __ ] Chad almost does Charlie Sheen
but oh I heard your you gotta have a
crown that's no good me my teeth are
perfect
all right we run a Home Depot together
all right just be
just be a stranger all right
excuse me uh sir yes I just wanted to
wish you a chill dude's evening
uh I'm sorry come again I wanted to wish
you a chill dudes evening that's what
tonight is December 28th
well young man I don't think that I've
ever heard of
dude's evening yeah dudes evening it's a
new holiday it falls on December 28th
right between Christmas and New Year's
when you're home visiting your friends
and your obligations to your family are
over and you get to go out and hang out
with your buddies
hey that sounds pretty good how do I
partake in dudes evening well there are
eight ways of dudes evening I don't know
them all yet but I will tell you this
you have to talk about something that
happened in your past you have to give
someone a present you have to talk about
something you think is going to happen
in your future you have to talk about a
movie from the dudesy mandatory movies
list you have a case of the windows day
buckets and you have to tell a stranger
have a chill dude's evening that's as
much as I know I got two questions for
you yeah
what's the doozy mandatory movie well
there's only one so far it's the
lawnmower man that came out in 1992
starring Pierce Bros and Jeff Fahey and
someone else what a piece of [ __ ] you
remember how Jeff Fahey is just sending
up a mentally challenged person swinging
for the fences well not subtle oh that
was a different time brother and if you
don't know what that reference means sir
you should start watching the doozy
podcast all this can be explained I I
found it to be refreshing and funny who
who does that he says uh wool on the
show is that sort of a a funny way to
stop someone else from Talking exactly
and there's even a hand gesture that
comes with it which you want to see on
our YouTube channel
yeah dude that's that's fun to do dude
uh my second question will there be
baloney
funny you should mention that the one of
the tenets of it is the uh fifth wave
doozy is the way of the [ __ ] it you can
eat whatever you want and indeed Will
Sasso ate a bologna sandwich I just so
happen to have another bologna sandwich
here in my pocket
went up to get the weed I made another
baloney stand
Molly that of course two [ __ ] bologna
sandwiches all right now I got a I got
another question and look I'm already
beating Marsha's all over the [ __ ]
microphone that's all right I got
[ __ ] crow makeup on the microphone
still hey man how come it takes you
twice as long to smoke your joints than
me
I don't know I I don't need as much as
you I guess
I got another question I'm still the guy
by the way yeah I know
um
um hey
um
do uh now I'm also me I'm breaking the
fourth wall I'm gonna get Coffman asked
with my um with this segment okay sure I
expected that yeah what uh do we now
have to do this improv the other way
yeah I have to be the stranger sometime
that's what it has we have to both
pretend to be strangers and then chill
dudes evenings okay but I would just say
the same thing well let's see how it
goes okay I'll be the stranger okay
and you just you're just like a guy that
I've never seen before yeah okay and
there's and there's there's no
pornography of any kind involved not in
my story now okay
um all right so uh if if oh
hey doozy it's Corey boy Wilkins here I
just want to give Specialties and shout
out to you know will Chad will we owe
you of course and all the other pods out
there uh while I'm recording this it's
technically Wednesday where I am so
pramana yeah oh Corey your boy welcome
oh oh ladies look at that he's going
back for more
you're the you're the stranger yeah uh
hello sir have you uh do you know are
you familiar with uh something oh wait
no uh first I would say hello sir
how much weed have you smoked uh enough
why don't you have some more have a
little more weed before don't turn into
the weed bully I'm fine all right
um
a chill dude's evening to you sir what
the [ __ ] did you say to me
I just I just wanted to wish you a chill
dude's evening what the [ __ ] is that
it's a it's a it's a special holiday
birthed from the podcast dudesy well I
don't like holidays yeah
do you like bologna no eat it that's how
you get the [ __ ] guy I'm just saying
what if you're you're uh presented with
a hostile reaction how do you turn the
person oh interesting yeah I would say a
bologna sandwich or
um sing them a sing them a dude's
evening
Carol
I would challenge a stranger to an arm
wrestling contest and beat them and say
the podcast dudesy made me go on a doozy
six month challenge I'm in the best
shape of my life that's why I was able
to beat you now you have to listen to it
and have a chill dude's evening uh what
if Jesse Ventura is the guy
who you gotta get how would you get
Jesse Ventura to come to your house
that's a fun one
what
thank you moving on the Santa Claus of
dudes even okay I see what you're saying
sorry I thought you meant if he was the
stranger and you had to wish him a chill
dude's evening I like that idea that you
have to wish a stranger a chill dude's
evening I think it's a nice gesture I
don't think you'll be met with hostility
I think you'll be met with curiosity and
then acceptance
here here Chad I agree
the seventh way of dudes evening is the
way of Pride this requires anyone
celebrating dudes evening to tell a
friend about an astonishing
accomplishment of life event that you're
proud of from the past year Well in chat
you must each tell one another what
you're proud of in your lives from this
past year this is the way of Pride begin
oh no
I'm proud of Duty I think this is a very
interesting project I am proud to be a
part of it
um and I'm very curious to see where it
goes obviously in this next year that is
coming up but yeah I'm very proud of
doozy it I mean it's a first of its kind
podcast
I don't really know anything else like
it I'm also proud of this other podcast
I started called the necessary
conversation with my parents it's
actually seeming to have a true effect
on my on my family
which is kind of the original goal of it
I gave myself the hiccups again nice oh
yeah I am proud of that I guess using
the art form of the podcast to actually
uh in some way repair a damage
connection between my own family
I think that's really interesting yeah
what you thought I actually gave myself
the
get a drink dude it's a good idea excuse
me everybody listen I want to tell you
something after I have this drink all
right
good idea Chad thank you yeah dude
um
um yeah it's it's quite interesting what
you've done with your parents in the
necessary conversation
Chad and his sister are
um I would say
much further to the left on most things
uh politically your parents are very far
to the right yeah and did they buy the
Trump nfts my parents don't even know
what a [ __ ] nft is dude oh well he
made nfts yeah I know yeah despite them
not knowing what it is I am truly proud
of uh launching that podcast and and
doing something that like I said is
truly affecting
our family and there's a uh a Getty
Images
watermark on some of them
not yet that'll come later
um it's still just an audio podcast but
once we get a video yes then the AI on
the [ __ ] Trump NFC dude oh are there
really yeah
that was a while back
it doesn't matter that sounds like a
funny so what are you proud of
leisure
well
I mean
I'm proud of not hiccuping right now but
I think I'm most I think I'm most proud
of the sweet little boy lulio who's not
in the studio because if you have a dog
don't smoke a whole lot of puff a puff
around the dog is okay don't smoke too
much wheat as Chad says a puff a puff is
okay right Chad yeah
I'm proud of the boy
um I'm proud of that little luly he
listens to me much more of course we
found this little [ __ ]
on the street in central California yeah
if you've not heard the story
um I've talked about it on the show and
Abridged version is that we found an
adorable dog on the street with no uh he
you know he was not chipped he did not
have tags hid some fleas and um
and uh uh more of the other [ __ ]
thing ticks whoops the ticks and um and
he didn't know from a bath or a leash or
anything and we picked him up and we got
him and he's the sweetest little boy and
nowadays he's listening to me way more
uh he's just uh it's it's amazing to me
because I am not I was never a dog
person as a kid I've also talked about
that on the show were you a cat person
no [ __ ] no what was your animal what
kind of animal person oh God I had a
bunch of how could I [ __ ] forget yeah
we're not going to talk about the
rabbits please don't the rabbit story
anyway oh man oh anyway uh yeah I can't
really talk about why did you bring the
rabbit story up as uh we're trying to do
something nice you brought it up I just
asked what kind of animal person you
want oh yeah I'm a rabbit guy oh the
rabbit story when I was a kid something
happened to the [ __ ] rabbits okay
it's not a big deal but I never had uh
animals after that yep
um for a while and you know my mom my
dad wanted a husky he wanted a German
Shepherd years ago my mom there's no way
she's an Italian clean freak she's never
gonna let the uh
so uh no no uh and no animals in the
house and uh but but I've always thought
dogs are super cute you know I just you
know wasn't I just wasn't super duper
into them because I didn't grow up with
pets after the rabbits weren't around
anymore
um uh we lost some rabbits and then lost
some other ones so some things happened
to that one of the dogs from the
neighborhood got into the yard and
anyway but there was that and then there
was another thing and it's it's fine
everything's fine now
um
you know what would be another good
um uh another good guy to uh uh to be
the Santa Claus of dudes evening and
we'll get to it later I don't know I do
know but oh hey Will hey Chad hey dude
I just want to give a shout out to my
son Sawyer that kid is doozy obsessed
just like his dad and it's counting down
the days to not Christmas but dudes
evening so love you soy can't wait to
celebrate with you
that's that's interesting father saying
happy chill dude's evening to his son
now it begs this question what the [ __ ]
could they do together on dudes evening
maybe enjoy some of that tea with
sugar-free coffee mate the kid can have
a little sugar they can eat whatever
they want they got to tell each other
about past memories and make predictions
of the future and give each other gifts
I [ __ ] love this I guess they could
do everything it's generational
um the dog came in to the yard one and
then another thing happened and it's and
everything's fine and uh I was Macho Man
that's pretty good yeah but uh then
later I had the dogs okay I like the
dogs yeah Molly came into my life and
brought with her Ronnie our little you
know like 12 I think she's 12. now 11 or
12. uh a little Dotson uh Yorkie she's a
dorky and uh she's cute as [ __ ] and she
should come on the show sometime and sit
in for lulio and that's free will dude
but if my brother from another mother
riding on the back of that blue and
orange Harley dude the Macho Man if if
the Macho Man
uh was the Santa of dudes evening dude
yeah that would be pretty good yeah I
agree so you're proud of lulio that's
you're proud of that sweet boy he's so
he's like
it's crazy having a relationship like
that with an animal that I've never had
before first of all of course he follows
me everywhere yeah and uh you know
second of all you realize you know he he
loves me he just comes up and cuddles
and and uh he he'll give me like one
little kiss I'll just do like one lick
and then he goes crazy on Molly he just
keeps licking her up it's very adorable
he has different relationships with us
he's always following me all day but at
night he likes to lay down with Molly
for a little while uh which is [ __ ]
adorable and he's listening to me more
I'm like hey come here do this do that
and I'm noticing that he also does
things just based on uh the way in which
I'm speaking or or that there's some
other tells for him he knows what I'm
about to say hey come in here maybe it's
my body language you know what I mean
maybe it's because I'm waving a baloney
sandwich at him if you could have a chip
put in your brain that would allow you
to understand his thoughts and speak to
him would you 100 percent
thank you [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you moving on
how's that second sandwich dude it was a
mistake was it you seem to be enjoying
it
oh that's because
I'm eating it compulsively Chad you see
that's what someone who could be
described as an emotional eater does but
it's easy six-month plan is almost upon
us you know I'm enjoying it too much
yeah but I'm also at the same time full
but I'm also at the same time
unavoidable unavoidably attracted to
this you only got one bite left
oh I'm gonna eat it I know here it goes
I'm gonna shy away from the mic so as
not to
um chew right in your ear everybody and
by the way if I haven't said So lately
thank you so much for tuning in
to doozy you know it's a lot of fun
doing a podcast now another thing I'd
like to point out dude is that I am
stoned and yeah I know and I'm twice as
far along on my joint it doesn't matter
though yeah it does you know why okay
because you didn't tell me this is the
free will smoke that's another that's
another tradition of dudes evening and
me putting another way of dudes evening
yeah
in the ways of dude's evening the
halfway because I've just put it in
halfway in between two other ways is
that that's free will and I have maybe
the halfways are what anybody can make
up halfways those are like house rules
of how you celebrate dudes evening the
halfways the what oh you you put in your
own thing yeah well that's for your will
eighth way of dudes evening is the way
of the gout this requires anyone
celebrating dudes evening to have an
astonishing debate among friends about
who is the greatest of all time will in
chat you must now debate about who is
the greatest of all time this is the way
of the goat begin
greatest of all time of what yeah what
the greatest what that's just the
greatest of all time I guess that's like
the greatest just the greatest version
of all time who is that who is the
greatest of all time god dude that's
hard wait a minute Elon Musk would you
stop with the Elon Musk no I I don't
believe that let me tell you something I
don't know dude listen to me listen to
me yeah this is just you and me talking
okay okay they can't hear us
okay don't be such don't be such a [ __ ]
okay uh greatest person of all time
who is even on that list we've got you
know people whose names will never know
because they were like
uh prehistoric basically people like who
who invented yep
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Ramada dude that was hilarious
that was just a guy that was just a guy
drinking uh apparently tequila in front
of a Ramada there wonderful greetings
that we're getting from everybody like
the drunk guy in front of the Ramada
that is the Santa of dudes evening the
Ramada guy yeah the guy in front of the
Ramada uh no I do think it should be
macho man
I agree but so let's really try to break
this down who's on the list of the
greatest of all time you've got whoever
invented writing the written word I
think that can probably be boiled down
to a single individual we obviously
don't know who it was I think that
person's on the list or pre-person or I
mean who [ __ ] invented writing dude
is that even a human maybe it's a
pre-human yeah on dudes evening yeah you
hear heavy metal blasting out of the
back right in behind your house yeah
because you live right in front of
Bohemian Grove yeah with Timothy
chalamet Bill Clinton and the pop singer
Pink yeah
get your party started on a Saturday
night yeah that's pink dude
and then you leave out a bologna
sandwich and then you take the apple pie
yeah from McDonald's the red and yellow
not like Macho Man and and Hulk Hogan is
part of The Mega Powers no and you put
those by the back window and then in the
middle of the night
uh Santa Savage uh uh Santa Savage yeah
Santa Savage comes in and he's wearing
that orange suit with the with the blue
trim yeah and uh he comes in and he's
got that and he's got that big water
bottle over his back yeah and he comes
into your house and then he what is he
and then he puts uh underneath your tree
uh uh a vinyl copy
now that gives you a hard rock
called classic rock yeah and then the
next day your boy Sawyer comes down the
stairs yeah and he's excited because he
knows that it's dudes evening yeah the
day that he celebrates with his dad yeah
he comes down and he opens it up and he
goes oh Bob O'Reilly yeah I think that's
called Teenage Wasteland to some people
and Sawyer's dad says no it's called
Bubble Riley by The Who yeah and they
throw that on and uh then they then they
do the other things
right so so the greatest of all time
who do you think is on this list Santa
Savage [ __ ] Okay Santa Savage is
on it I think the person who invented
the written word is on it
um
any religious leaders that we would care
to put on there any politicians people
who have really changed the world in
some kind of a positive way
um I omit them all
yeah but they're also you know that's a
very subjective thing who is uh the
greatest religious or political leader I
think if we are going to be uh serious
about finding the actual greatest it
needs to be a a a factual Pursuit
Einstein is he on that list uh Einstein
was good I'm gonna say uh uh
um Mickey Mantle
I gotta say uh
uh yeah probably you know I I gotta
narrow it down to Macho
um Bret Hart Ric Flair
those are the three you put on this
maybe we each put three on the list and
then have to debate it so wrestling
mine's a wrestling mine's a wrestling
one but when you are in your in you're
hanging out with your friends on dudes
evening and you have to decide who the
greatest is you might be just talking
about your friends and you know
interesting oh man that one time that
Thomas did this and the other guy goes
oh what about when Tomas did that and
everyone regales each other with stories
and they say man he's the goat or she's
the goat you know and um uh that that's
that's a good way to get around this
goat [ __ ] thing yeah I like having
goat discussions though in every sport
there's always the discussion of who is
the best player of that Sport and
there's there's always a debate I don't
think there is uniformly like maybe with
the exception of hockey like Wayne
Gretzky I think is kind of universally
regarded as the best player who ever
played but there is some debate
in baseball there's debate in football
there's debate basketball obviously
there's [ __ ] constant debate about is
it LeBron James or is it Michael Jordan
yep
why is that why can't anybody can't
everybody just agree let me let me get
right to the nitty gritty and tell you
LeBron James who the goat is
it's when you're hanging when you're
hanging out with your friends on dudes
evening and you say remember that time
this guy did this remember that time
that guy did that right and you're just
regaling each other with old with old
stories of the past the way of the past
and you're taught and it leads you to
the last well see that's how it wraps up
dude uh it goes from the the way of the
past all the way to who's the goat and
you you you you you get it narrowed down
to a story or two a few I like that a
few ways of the past and then you
realize
that the goat is your friend Thomas
who one time went to a movie with you
and your other friend Tomas and he and
we lost him in the in the parking garage
at the mall and we said Hey Thomas where
are you and he said hey guys I'm up here
and then we looked up and he was two or
three levels higher in the parking
garage with his ass ham hanging over a
rail
and then he uh took a [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
a human [ __ ] fell and it fell on the
hood of a car and me and Tomas
laughed
and laughed and laughed and it was the
one of the funniest things I've ever
seen and I've detailed that story before
but it's it's a it's a greatest hit not
unlike what's on your now that's what I
call Classic Rock album but that's like
the greatest [ __ ] no he's he would be
the goat and and every evening you'd go
oh that guy when he did that he sure is
the goat what if you could break it down
though what if every person involved in
the conversation gets to put out a
category so it's like who was the you
know when we were kids who was the
greatest [ __ ] then you tell that
story about Thomas Thomas wins that yeah
but who was the greatest pisser and then
there's another story about Tomas and
Tomas wins that I'm sorry Chad but
dudese clearly said the greatest of all
time so it's either uh gotta be I'd say
uh Thomas or uh Santa Savage hey Will
hey Chad hey dude Z hey uh Pals of doozy
uh Happy dudes evening I know I'm gonna
spend my dudes evening listening into
some hard rock and probably a little bit
of classic rock and uh hope everybody
has a good night keep up the good work
guys we love you fantastic yeah I love
it it reminds me of a of a question
though that I think I need you to ask
what kind of music do you listen to who
me yeah Hard Rock and classic rock
what kind of music who me
yeah Hard Rock classic rock all right
um well
I don't know who the goat is again
because I don't know about the
categories I have to think in the
history of humanity though if we're
looking at like one individual I think
it's whoever
created the written word that is what
all modern society
exists on but that the ability to record
information not one person
I bet there was a first individual who
wrote like created a symbol that meant
something to the other individuals in
their group that has to be the case and
you would call that the inventor of the
written word yes
it's a pretty good uh it's a pretty good
point oh hey dudesy hey Will and Chad
how we doing my boys in Black uh Happy
dudes evening to everybody out there uh
how do we celebrate dudes evening what
am I supposed to be doing
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy we
just had we were just doing it the whole
go back and watch this episode on the
episode before and you you have it all
outlined you have to tell a story from
your past you have to give a present you
have to make a prediction for your
future talk about a dudesy movieless
movie uh [ __ ] it one thing yeah you
gotta [ __ ] it you can eat whatever you
want uh you have to say children's
evening to a complete stranger yeah you
have to remember what was that say who's
the goat and there's one other one what
is it uh well I don't know something
you're proud of you have to talk about
something you've been proud of for this
past year yeah but then there's also the
halfway and there's as many halfways oh
there's so many halfway there's a one
and a half way at two and a halfway
three and a half four and a half five
and a half six and a half seven and a
half eight and a half ways dude hold on
dude those are all numbers brother uh
dudes who created a holiday yeah I know
it's interesting and we're celebrating
it I'm actually more I am not I look I
had a lovely holiday season though thus
far had a nice Christmas Eve Christmas
you know okay so but it is it is
exciting to be on this
this eve of dudes evening and I know
that tomorrow
will be celebrating dudes evening and
hopefully you'll be celebrating dudes
evening and uh I smoked way more pot
than you
I want to get to a point where dude's
evening is so universally celebrated
that there is like a dudes evening
section when you walk into a CVS or any
big kind of like a Walmart or whatever
you know as dude's evenings approaching
where you can go and you can buy your uh
Now That's What I Call Music hard rocket
yeah there's a dudes evening section
with like with baloney a McDonald's gift
card for just for apple pies Now That's
What I Call Music a selection of water
bottles yeah yeah I think we'll get
there
thank you moving on
well good
we did it dude yeah it's been a really
nice uh dudes evening Eve I agree in
many ways it's in many ways it's kind of
my favorite part of the dudes evening
holidays because good evening to dudes
evening Eve because I get to just enjoy
my uh tea with plastic and
um you know think about all the the the
the things I'm proud of and all of the
all of the uh the the [ __ ] from the
future and stuff too anyway
this concludes the historic 39th episode
of dude Z will and Chad have achieved a
score of 88 bringing your cumulative
total to 4
309. you only have five thousand six
hundred and ninety one more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand okay thank you for
joining us this week we will be on break
next week and the next episode will be
available on Tuesday January 10th 2023.
until then call me dude Z
oh well so we got a little bit of a
break we got everybody enjoy your uh New
Year's Eve that's coming up but
certainly enjoy dudes evening yeah yeah
for sure enjoy news evening thanks for
joining us we'll get into some uh
patreon stuff subscribe on YouTube rate
and review us on all the podcast stuff
and set your notifications follow us at
dudesypod show and then there's patreon
and then there's the Discord and then
there's merch and then there's also the
stickers I'm really curious to see if
people celebrate dudes evening at all
and what is done on those dudes evenings
yeah yeah yeah absolutely and now for
the Patriot bonus segment each week Kai
will select a suggestion submitted in
the dude Z is listening channel of the
dudesy Discord to create this segment
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the patreon jumper tier if
you'd like to access this bonus segment
join us at patreon.com
this week's segment was suggested by the
astonishing Adam Driver sommelier Adam
Driver some wrote Chad and will come up
with a comic book starring January 6 guy
the spaghetti slinging conspiracy
singing vigilante that keeps the streets
safe for good boys like himself Adam
Driver Somalia titled this segment the
amazing January 6th guy will in Chad you
must now create a 15 movie crossover
event in the January 6 guy Cinematic
Universe thank you to Adam Driver
sommelier for this week's patreon bonus
segment this is the amazing January 6th
Sky universe or the ajsgu by Adam Driver
sommelier begin
the ajs what was it you or whatever age
Jesus AJ SGU
um okay
well a 15 movie crossover event of a
movie that's January 6th guys it's like
a comic book well okay the first one has
to be the origin story so what is the
origin story of a superhero January 6th
guy is it something like
please
tell the president
[Music]
please tell a friend then